Gronk we all saw the Tweet uh can you
break down this photo for us please did
he do it right
um I don't think he did it right I think
everything's right but his hand is not
in the right place he's covering up a
little bit you're not you're not
supposed to be covering up that's what's
supposed to be showing you got to show
the package Tom Rob Gronkowski shares
his opinion about former teammate Tom
Brady's recent thirst trap
the newly retired NFL star shared this
stripped down pick on Twitter as for why
we have Gronk to explain I guess he put
a tweet out on uh on his uh what a Brady
brand that said if I get 40 000 likes or
something I'll post a picture in my
underwear yeah it's a bet Tom clearly
lost he captioned the post did I do it
right tagging his Pals Julian Edelman
and Gronk I think everything's right but
his hand is not in the right place he's
covering up a little bit you're not
you're not supposed to be covering up
that's what's supposed to be showing you
got to show the package Tom so that so
everything looks good besides his hand
placement you know came through with his
promise so when I saw that I was a
little shocked I was like Tom posing in
his underwear doing selfies in the
mirror
uncharacteristic of him that's for sure
but well that's what we love about Tom
when he throws a curveball it's always
you know it's always for the fun and uh
it's always great to see him doing that
like Tom
hired and preparing
Gronk beat very own music
third grind Beach our first one we did
was I was retired in Miami three years
ago and then we did one last year at the
draft in um in Las Vegas and that was
super successful and uh and now we got
this one for the third annual Gronk
Beach and it just keeps getting better
every single time
foreign